it's a really weird story I wanted to
share with you coming out of Germany a
politician from Hamburg Germany I'm
sorry where's that music coming from do
you hear that music Andy yeah well but I
guess I mean it's not that loud
[Music]
idiot Islam what's going on with your
lectern what is that
Oh oh this okay well listen yo my cousin
was arrested by Park Rangers for doing
that really creepy thing in Griffith
Park no my family's collecting bail
money to get my cousin out of jail and
to replace the RV that he damaged and to
buy that little girl a new pony so I
thought I'd make some extra money by
getting a sponsor for my lectern
tonight's lectern is sponsored by gold
Leonard ten in one sport jail for men
penny I didn't approve any of this well
yeah that's why I didn't ask you is it
okay if I show the ad for the body gel
no Andy it's not okay thanks Conan
Rowley Billy real guys don't buy ten
bottles when they can buy just one
introducing gold winner ten in one sport
gel for men a shampoo conditioner and
body soap all in one it's also a
toothpaste
eyedrops plus it's an engine additive a
sex lubricant and a life-saving heart
reviving of trevelin injection and the
best sports drink you've ever had
[Music]
so uh well what do you think that is
awful that's terrible and now you're
stuck with that stupid lectern oh no I'm
not because ten and one sports gel is
also very flammable
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
you